when she does talk like you're listening
yeah oh my god last time I was like who
are you you're brilliant I know my god
he's the cutest I think I'll be able to
see my entire life
I'm just gonna take him and I just want
to my his little ears off I just wanna
take his little legs and just like that
I'm like little like like chicken drum
at ya take his fuzzy little perfect head
I want to put it in my mouth and squeeze
down on it hard until I have a puppy
face diamond England soon I feel like I
have to wrap his face in a towel and I
beat it with a tire iron I'm going to
buy that dog I'm going to drive him to
the vet and I'm going to have him put
down immediately oh my god you know I'm
gonna have to do I'm gonna want to take
that scruffy little nose yeah and just
kick it I just have to I would kick it
until it comes off on my shoes like
little puppy snout slippers and I'm and
I'm gonna go to a party now it's like oh
my god would you give the slippers
milites this is my face slippers my
adorable dumb little pony that's exactly
what I was going to say I just want to
take his head I'm healed the skin off of
his skull I know where you're going I
wanted to start throwing it up like
pizza dough until it's long flat and
round I want to take it to a picnic and
toss it around like a frisbee and a
puppy face frisbee get yeah let's get it
so cute so cute oh my god is it me or is
it like totally mosquito-y out here oh
my god remember this one it was so cute
we will do this best we can do but man
I've got more I've got